[Music]
on this friday night papal plans
confirmed i wanted to wave like me and
say hey this is for you too
high hopes and mixed reaction to the
pontiff's canadian tour for
reconciliation how is he going to be
able to address such a large number of
first nation communities that were
directly impacted
mourning a slain journalist in jerusalem
and how violence erupted at shireen abu
aklay's funeral this tragic killing
fuels the flames
of palestinian anger and frustration
unity for ukraine it's a recognition of
the tragic moments for which our region
is going through as g7 leaders meet the
trial begins for a russian soldier in a
ukrainian court
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
the vatican has confirmed pope francis
will go ahead with plans to visit canada
this summer in what will mark the fourth
ever papal visit to this country it
comes after last month's historic
apology for what the pope called
deplorable conduct of some members of
the catholic church in the residential
school system indigenous delegates
expressed they believed a more in-depth
apology should be made on canadian soil
the pope will arrive in canada on july
24th making stops in edmonton ecallute
and quebec city he will leave the
country on july 29th a longer than
expected trip for the 85 year old
pontiff who is struggling with a bad
knee as heather urex west explains for
survivors of the residential school
system and their children the
expectations for this visit are high
after generations of suffering and pain
the apology from pope francis to
residential school victims and survivors
last month was a landmark moment deeply
meaningful for many but it was also just
the beginning of a new chapter francis
promised to come to canada too i need to
heal from
from
the past
and i need to
i need it for my children too
they need to learn what forgiveness is
for mary jane mitchell healing requires
hearing from the pope himself soon she
will have that chance the vatican says
the pontiff will be visiting her
community in edmonton i want to wave at
me and say hey
you know
this is for you too the full trip will
also include stops in quebec city and
iqaluit and while a formal program won't
be announced next month certainly we
will
have the pope visit a former residential
school site and other locations of
significance it was one year ago this
month that the kim lives to schweitman
first nation announced up to 215
unmarked graves had been discovered near
the site of the former kamloops
residential school the graves of
children who never made it home
triggered an international reckoning
over canada and the church's role in the
decades of horrific abuse
for more than 100 years indigenous
children were ripped from their
communities and their families forced to
attend institutions where physical
emotional and sexual abuse were
commonplace
cook me roseanne kashmir of the tekam
loops to schweitman first nation
extended an invitation to the pope
directly when she met with him at the
vatican she says she is still hopeful he
will when i think about the impact of
you know our survivors and our
intergenerational survivors
it really truly would be a tragedy if he
came to canada
you know and not visited a first nation
community that's been directly impacted
um from unmarked graves the canadian
conference of catholic bishops says that
at 85 the pope's advanced age and the
fact that he now relies on a wheelchair
was considered when planning the trip
indigenous leaders say that means the
work to accommodate him now falls to
them we all have to find a way now to
how do we
how do we include ourselves
and our nations and our survivors
uh when it comes to edmonton
so i guess the planning begins the aim
will be to ensure that as many survivors
that want to can experience the pope's
visit firsthand
many have been waiting a lifetime
heather urex west global news calgary
we understand these stories may be
distressing for some viewers and a
reminder there is support available for
survivors and their families the number
is toll-free and open 24 hours a day
1-800-721-0066
a manitoba first nation is working to
rebuild after historic floods forced
nearly 2 000 people to flee their homes
this week some residents are now
returning to pegus first nation but as
martin blunt reports the full extent of
the damage won't be known for some time
the water is receding and much of the
damage has been done but for peg was
first nation the fight against the flood
is far from over we're still in
emergency mode you know we have a lot of
water still in homes and overland
flooding that we're dealing with right
now some cleanup and repair is already
underway an estimated 700 homes were
flooded out and damaged by the rapidly
rising water and the community is hoping
additional rain will stay at bay it's
humbling you know that some of the
people just scattered right away like
you know and left everything one on a
minutes noticed and
that's what really hits home it's hard
arnold flett is one of those people who
dropped everything and left i just want
to come home from it he's staying at a
winnipeg hotel but wanted to come back
to check on his home and his relative's
home assessing the devastation and
trying to salvage what he can it
happened so fast but
water came up pretty fast officials say
the north part of the community was the
hardest hit and the least protected by
the time it reached that area the flood
waters were too powerful and the
situation too dangerous there's nothing
we can do right at that time during the
height of the crisis
and seeing the strength of the water
it's just too dangerous to send crews
out there a devastating time for a
close-knit community but one they plan
to pull through together just bear with
us for the time being you know we'll
we'll get through this we will more than
1900 people have evacuated the community
and while some are able to return home
temporarily to assess the damage there's
still no word on when they'll be able to
come back for good nitu
marnie blunt in pegus first nation
thanks marnie the war in ukraine now for
the first time since russia's invasion a
russian soldier has appeared on trial
for war crimes the serviceman appeared
in a key court accused of murdering a
62-year-old ukrainian civilian and as
the war rages on ukraine's foreign
minister met with his g7 counterparts in
germany he says he wants western nations
to follow canada's lead in targeting
russian assets redmond shannon
reports meeting on germany's baltic
coast the g7 foreign ministers line up
for the annual family photo and then
welcome in their two guests their
counterparts from ukraine and its
neighbor moldova that's an honor but at
the same time that's a recognition of
the tragic moments for which
our region is going through as ministers
seek ways to help ukraine export its
grain the european union announced
almost 700 million dollars in new
military aid hungary's government though
is threatening to veto an eu ban on
russian oil
ukraine says that would send the wrong
signal
if this package is inclu is adopted
without oil embargo i believe president
putin can celebrate
ukraine's foreign minister saved perhaps
his warmest greeting for canada's
melanie jolie dressed in ukrainian
colours he highlighted proposed
legislation in canada that if passed
could allow seized russian assets to be
used to help rebuild ukraine canada has
already done so
and
i have a feeling that
others will reach that point
rather sooner than later on the front
lines this footage released by ukraine's
armed forces claims to show a
significant victory they say a russian
battalion lost almost all of its armored
vehicles in its repeated attempts to
cross a river in the contested donbass
region
russia meanwhile claims to have taken
out an oil refinery and an arms depot
in kiev a landmark moment ukraine begins
its first war crimes trial connected to
the february invasion
this russian soldier accused of
murdering a civilian has yet to enter a
plea and could face life in prison
ukraine says it has identified thousands
more potential war crimes redmond
shannon global news london
turkey's president says it's not
possible to support sweden and finland's
nato membership bid because he claims
the two countries are home to many
terrorist organizations in the past nato
member turkey has criticized sweden and
other european countries for their
handling of organizations deemed to be
terrorists president rejected erdogan's
comments come a day after finland said
it would seek membership sweden is
expected to also apply as early as
monday
thousands crowded the streets of
jerusalem today for the funeral of an al
jazeera journalist shireen abu aklay was
shot earlier this week while covering a
military raid in the occupied west bank
her death has been met with violence and
outrage and this afternoon as she was
moved to her final resting place was no
different mike drollet has more
for the briefest of moments the israeli
police and palestinian crowd held their
ground but this was a powder keg ready
to go off and as police pushed back
crowds with batons and nearly horrifying
moment
mourners carrying the coffin of
journalist shireen abu at clay stumble
almost dropping her to the ground the
dispute police wanted them to use a
hearse the crowd wanted to walk
a veteran journalist working for al
jazeera was killed on wednesday she was
reporting on an israeli raid into the
occupied west bank when she was shot in
the head she was wearing a press jacket
ali al-samudi another journalist who was
wounded says israeli snipers are to
blame
they shot us for no reason he says it
was obvious we were journalists but
israeli officials say it's impossible to
know who fired the shot without
examining the fatal bullet suggesting a
joint investigation a request rejected
outright by palestinians
there needs to be an investigation to
calm things down although i doubt that
the side that is blamed if it comes to
that
for the journalists death will not
accept those results anyway
was a palestinian-american with years of
experience reporting from the front
lines of conflict in the middle east
i spoke with her 10 days ago her voice
still rings in my ear says his colleague
from al jazeera
mere days after her death she's being
hailed as a martyr of the free word by
the palestinian authority which also
wants those responsible tried by the
international criminal court and we have
to understand that this
tragic
killing of
a war journalist that has been dear to
the palestinians for
decades
it fuels the flames
of
palestinian
anger and
frustration about the lack of resolution
of this conflict abu aklay once said all
she hoped for was to give a voice to
those suffering now her death may be
seen by some as a reason to keep
fighting mike dralet global news
coming up the violent crime defense
landmark ruling by canada's top court
the supreme court of canada has
delivered what could be a landmark
ruling that would allow those accused of
violent crimes including sexual assault
to use a defense known as self-induced
extreme intoxication the court ruling
says there are some instances when an
accused person on drugs commits conduct
that can be involuntary and cannot be
held guilty for their actions let's go
now to our david aiken in ottawa to
explain more david
there were two cases before the courtney
to both involving individuals who had
consumed magic mushrooms these are drugs
that are hallucinogens and then they
committed horrific crimes including in
one case murder in both cases the
defense argued the accused person had
lost their minds after consuming the
drugs and temporarily had no ability to
know what it was they were doing this
state of mind is called automatism it's
different than being just high or drunk
it is a temporary psychosis and so the
defense argued each defendant could not
be held responsible for their acts by
reason of automatism
now in each case prosecutors said no
parliament back in 1994 amended the
criminal code to remove that defense
saying in effect if you voluntarily take
the drugs and then commit a crime you
are criminally responsible but the
supreme court now says that 1994 change
to the criminal code it's
unconstitutional it violates charter
rights of an accused and as a result in
the cases before the court the defense
of automatism was allowed i don't expect
to ever have a case like this again
what people need to know is that extreme
intoxication defenses are exceedingly
rare and exceedingly difficult to
establish some now worry that the
supreme court's decision will remove a
protection that many women and children
relied on in domestic and sexual assault
cases where an individual usually a man
could beat a charge of rape or sexual
assault by claiming they were high and
we're going to see
some men become
extremely intoxicated commit violence
and be acquitted as a result of this
decision today
so now it's up to parliamentarians to
figure out what to do next the
conservatives want action to rebalance
the law toward victims justice minister
david lametty said today he is reviewing
the ruling before committing to next
steps nithu
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
elon musk says his 44 billion dollar
deal to buy twitter is temporarily on
hold he made the announcement on where
else twitter he says he's waiting for
information supporting the calculation
that spam and fake accounts do indeed
represent less than five percent of
users musk later added he is still
committed to the acquisition
analysts speculate he could be seeking
to renegotiate the price or even walk
away from the takeover
ahead the calls to combat disastrous
impacts of heat across canada
[Music]
in india tonight a massive fire erupted
at a four-story commercial building in
the capital at least 27 people have been
killed and more than 30 injured dozens
have been rescued from the building
which primarily contains shops a search
operation is underway to look for anyone
trapped in the rubble the cause of the
fire is still not known
thirty thousand more canadians died over
the course of the pandemic than would be
expected in normal years but not all of
them were due to covet nineteen as jamie
morocco explains experts say an
unsuspecting cause of mortality we can't
ignore is heat
the more it feels like summer the more
bc paramedic ian tate worries we aren't
ready for more scorching heat like last
summer's deadly heat dome the 911 system
collapsed it was kind of like an
all-around apocalypse perfect storm kind
of thing the 2021 heat dome coincided
with more than 3 500 deaths over two
weeks in alberta nbc according to
statistics canada contributing to a near
six percent jump in the country's
overall mortality rate
those regions likely won't be spared
this year either the areas that are
going to hit the hardest are the
southern regions of central british
columbia in the valley regions the area
of the prairies alberta and saskatchewan
bordering the united states is going to
be particularly hot and the north shore
of lake erie extending on through to the
st lawrence river valley i'm just
outside of toronto where the
temperatures are unseasonably warm now
in the depths of the summer this area
can reach 37 degrees celsius there's
around 15 to 20 days during the season
where it's above 30 degrees but by 2050
climatologists believe
we will triple that number and we'll top
out around 42 degrees
different provinces track deaths due to
heat differently that can affect how
people whose deaths may be linked to
pre-existing conditions are recorded but
it does nothing to change our
vulnerability
young children seniors and those without
a home are at greatest risk dr kyle
merritt worked in an er in the bc
interior during the heat dome and
charted climate change as the cause of
patient symptoms
i felt like i was starting to see the
actual impacts happening and i thought
it should be recorded
this is how we advance
things in medicine and something he
feels he'll continue to run into as
extreme temperatures put more canadians
at risk jamie morocco global news
toronto
coming up a grim effect of drought
dropping water levels reveals secrets
buried in lake mead
severe weather rolling through nebraska
caught drivers off guard last night
covering the highway in a cloud of dust
in a matter of seconds the storm carried
winds of more than 160 kilometers per
hour and was under investigation as a
possible tornado however experts say
straight line winds caused the storm
creating the dangerous blackout
conditions
in america's southwest the problem
continues to be severe drought
conditions for years now the region has
been drying up leading to critical water
shortages in several states including
california and nevada but in the latter
new mysteries are being revealed as the
water recedes jennifer johnson explains
how the changing climate is leading to
grim discoveries beneath one of the
country's biggest bodies of water
parts of the american west are burning
and drying up but that's nothing new
climate change is fueling what's now
become a 22-year mega drought also
drying up america's largest reservoir
lake mead outside las vegas which 20
million americans rely on for water
lake mead delivers water to nevada
arizona california and mexico about 75
percent of the water goes to
irrigation for agriculture that supplies
about 60 percent of the food for the
nation but what's happening below the
lake surface is what's really making
headlines two human bodies have been
discovered one hidden in a barrel still
dressed in 1970s clothing
those who remember the old days of las
vegas think organized crime could be
responsible if they're able to identify
the caliber bullet that will tell them
an awful lot as to whether or not this
is a quote mob hit or not for years
tourists and locals have come to splash
and play on the lake now all the talk is
about the secrets below crashed planes
prehistoric salt mines and the bodies a
former las vegas police officer turned
podcast host is offering a 5 000 reward
for qualified divers if they find more
bodies in the lake now over the next few
weeks they state that the levels will go
maybe 20 feet less
lower you know so the west really comes
down to what will be uncovered over the
next 30 or 60 days there's concerns that
there are other bodies colemeyer says
he's already heard from divers willing
to try and from families still searching
for missing loved ones the massive lake
may have helped conceal evidence of foul
play for decades i think people think
with vegas and sin city that's totally
mafia related it's probably interesting
it probably won't come up that way it
probably will come up it's just like a
regular homicide that's that's covered
up but lake mead's cover is wilting away
6 trillion gallons of water have now
evaporated experts predict as the
drought enters its 23rd year more water
will be lost and more bodies of the
missing may come to life
jennifer johnson global news washington
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm nitu garcia tonight's
your canada is the red rocks of dennis
beach near alma new brunswick we love
seeing your canada so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching sophie louis will be
with you tomorrow have a great weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]